et maintenant j'accueille jacky
[Musique]
dis moi dix lits oui tu comptes sur les
césars toi à jouer pour l'été meurtrier
tu veux dire politi meurtrier ouais
j'espère l'avoir oui tu risques c'est
sûr on regarde je peux te prends un peu
tôt le net
oui
comme ça tu aimes bien les canards quoi
il serait bien qu'il fasse une petite
imitation non
pour les téléspectateurs de platine 45
alors maintenant po lyon 1
dans come back and stay voilà
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
jacky chez lui en région parisienne en
plein milieu d'un inventeur un peu
étrange bonjour ma rentrée rentrer chez
moi je vais d'abord vous montrer
malgré son cochon ça peut être sympa
[Musique]
la collection cochon c'est ma femme et
moi même qui avons décidé de la faire
parce que quand on était quand on s'est
connus je sais pas on se re était de
cochon et [ __ ] on s'est dit tiens on
va aux fans que l'exemple que le son
voilà je suis là je lui ai acheté à new
york sans carton pâte j'adore voilà dans
l'it à l'italie bon il a dû coûter au
moins
10 dollars américains elle est
magnifique voilà bien la peggy la
[ __ ] dit bonjour
mais ses passions ne se résume pas aux
cochons grand mélomane jacky possède un
vrai trésor de musique qui ont marqué sa
vie
sans déposer mes vinyles
alors voilà un peu c'est un peu
n'importe quoi s'est pas rangé par
l'alphabet tic s'est rangé c'est jacky
quoi c'est l'ordre de jacky donc quand
ma femme ma fille rentre ici toute façon
elles peuvent pas trouver qu'elles
veulent genesis c'est un double album
s'appelle m la zone de broadway c'est
indéniable au café peter gabriel au sein
de genesis et à l'époque j'étais attaché
de presse donc ça m'évoque ça m'évoque
le concert au palais des sports je
m'occupais deux essais un album
magnifique roxy music un album que
j'adore avalon pareil je veut s'occuper
de roxy music et ça me rappelle c'est
bon on était fin 70 ça me rappelle plein
de choses à l'époque à l'époque où
j'avais pas encore 30 ans où je
connaissais pas ma femme quand est ce
que je veux dire bon hein
[Musique]
et c'est en musique que jacky trouve
l'inspiration pour écrire l'une de ces
deux émissions quotidiennes
les news je les fais en arrivant et des
f1 vers 14 heures par contre les
questions pour l'inviter c'est là ça se
passe
donc je prends mon stylo et je prends
donc ier où qu'ils aillent raid question
pour l'inviter s'appelle des
qualications comme invité mon interview
au sujet de la dure à peu près un quart
d'heure donc j'ai pas mal alors j'ai une
manière aussi assez spécial prévoir des
interviews j'ai un fil rouge je pense
qu'avec des questions je ne prépare pas
intérieur de questions et souvent j'ai
une technique à moi de l'interview c'est
à dire que je revends dit sur la réponse
de mon invitée voilà j'arrive je suis là
du lundi au vendredi j'ai deux émissions
en direct et là il est temps que je
préfère la première qui s'appelle le jjd
à voile à s'user mois
[Musique]
alors ça c'est mon bureau je lui met
d'ailleurs si tu veux voilà
je fais mes news tu vois tout n'est pas
trompeur dont j'ai bien tout est inscrit
là comme ça donc je fais mes news pour
lancer les jingle je le fais avec comme
ça avec mon jingle la musique c'est moi
qui l' affaire ça fait un tabac par
internet à la jungle voilà ça pour
lancer les news
mais avant l'antenne il doit se refaire
une beauté
cette fois ci qui nowacki donc pour mes
deux émissions et sa valve mais qui pas
trop mal tu refais pas longtemps tu m'as
qui serait quand même temps tu as fait
des provinces par tant de mois est sympa
j'en laisse maquillés par une
maquilleuse qui maquille que depuis deux
mois
son adn c'est l'union et c'est bien cela
qui a séduit jean luc azoulay producteur
et président d'idf un détour par son
bureau avant enregistrement de
l'émission
[Musique]
la salle jean luc azoulay là bas c'est
l'animateur le plus le plus animé
moi je m'en fous
cela fait maintenant plus de trente ans
que les deux hommes travaillent
régulièrement ensemble les cours
discussion
excusez moi je vais faire les missions
d'un
oui ah oui attention à charles henry
comme l'héritier charland
[Musique]
voilà générique général jean et
attention je touche exotique
inscrivez vous c'est peut-être vous
devrez ici
les années ont passé mais jacky a su
rester le grand enfant délurée du paf et
ça lui va bien
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
jacky jacky bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde va parler vous êtes né le
30 avril 1948 dans le 19e arrondissement
de paris mais votre père ne vous déclare
que le 1er mai oui bah je suis à 30
avril à 23h30 ah oui donc c'était un peu
délicat donc il était un des premiers
mais il était tellement il a dit voilà
mon fils est né le 1er mai avec du
muguet partout c'est sympa alors votre
nom d'état civil c'est jacques
jacubowicz vous êtes d'une famille juive
ashkénaze d'origine polonaise pas du
tout radis chez vous on mange pas cacher
ne fait pas ça bah en fait les trois
grandes fêtes évidemment rosh hashana
qui pourrait pessah mais c'est tout lire
plus tard vous marierait avec une
catholique et vos deux filles seront
élevés chez les bonnes soeurs
en revanche vous dites je me sens de
culture juive avec un humour juif fait
de dérision et d'autodérision très
eskenazy je suis complètement juifs
ashkénazes j'adore woody allen mel
brooks tout ça enfin oui je pratique
l'autodérision tous les jours
alors vous êtes fils unique mère très
possessive 1 qui chute à mort ah oui
c'est même incroyable j'en étais même
gêné j'étais dans les jupons de ma mère
bon après ça s'est mieux passé mais très
possessive alors vous dit j'aurais pu
devenir beaucoup plus chiant fait déjà
pas mal de chien gens plus beaucoup plus
chiant très égoïste tout ça mais enfin
bon après ça s'est arrangé alors votre
père est dans la shdm at d'abord
tailleur ensuite boutique de fringues
boutique il aurait aimé vous voir
reprendre j'imagine non à c'était son
rêve la tradition de père en fille chez
les juifs ashkénazes c'est comme ça quoi
nous laisser faire dire de père en fils
mais non j'ai vite compris ce n'était
pas pour moi et lui il a compris un peu
plus tard ce n'était pas pour moi non
plus lui il était arrivé dans les années
30 s'il arrive en 36
de pologne parce que ça chauffe est
quand même là bas pour les juifs il n'y
avait pas permis de travail s'est
débrouillé et puis voilà bien réussie où
il a réussi oui la russie 11 ans vous
partez dans une colonie de vacances
juive laïque à verberie dans l'oise et
là vous rencontrer richard gotainer qui
deviendra vite votre inséparable annie
déjà on faisait des conneries à 11 en
quoi c'est là que j'ai commencé à voir
là la fibre artistique les sketches on
se relaie pour poiret serrault on
n'était ni pourrait ne servir
que là vous l'enfant couvent et vous
découvrez avec lui le drôle de jeu qui
consiste à manger des araignées vivantes
des faucheurs exactement
entre autres mais vous écrire des
sketches chansons plus tard donc vers 18
ans oui absolument ont passé dans les
cabarets en auditeur libre notamment à
l'échelle de jacob on était passé en
première partie de thierry le luron je
me souviens mais enfin personne nous
écouter a passé de rigoler avec les
bruits de fourchettes et dacia dont deux
en se disant ça on va essayer de faire
un truc mais séparément tout en restant
neutre raoult fait vos études au lycée
voltaire il l'a va arriver là la vraie
transformation est une révolution la
découverte du rock'n'roll à 15 ans vous
partez à londres et là vous découvrez
les beatles les stones les who les
animals les kinks et réclame simple et
le marquis et j'ai vu tous ces groupes
là donc là samassa à 15 ans ça m'a
appris à la tête et ça m'avait
aujourd'hui encore j'écoute du rock and
roll voilà ça le change et été une année
très importante pour moi oui alors vous
n'attendez pas donc 68 pour faire votre
révolution mode sex drugs and
rock'n'roll à l'époque j'ai déjà le look
rock quand vous rentrez de londres les
cheveux longs des cachemires jacquard au
nombre des vestes carnaby street
les premiers cris passe alors vous
imaginez mon père qui faisait des
costumes sur mesure
ils étaient effrayés quand vous voyez
les rentrées de longues surtout la
première fois pour un terrible terrible
mais j'ai tenu bon quoi
alors vous réussissez quand même obtenir
le bac philo oui et un diplôme de
journaliste à l'école de la rue de
rennes en revanche service militaire est
obligé d'y aller mon père m'a quand même
pistonné méchoui d'alger réussit quand
même faire former ou trois mois j'étais
dans les sillons wee
b à 117
place balard hélas en 1973 chez le
coiffeur vont rencontrer daisy lama l'ex
femme de serge lama qui était attachée
de presse chez philips en grosse blind à
l'époque et vous trouve marrant oui et
elle nous engage comme assistant il a
fallu que je passe un que je passe un
entretien avec le directeur de la promo
qui s'appelait louis nucéra l'époque qui
après a été directeur littéraire chez
lattès il a été très sympa d'ailleurs il
m'a reçue c'était plus qu assistant
d'ailleurs ils veulent extraire un peu
attachés de presse et donc il me reçoit
dans son bureau mais le désigne prévient
dit voilà que s'il voit plusieurs
personnes se passe sur ce prétoire
j'arrive dans son bureau je reste 10
minutes debout ne dit pas de m'asseoir
dont je reste debout le secours
islamique aeni soit une d'imanol tu peux
t'asseoir sur il m'a posé de questions
il m'a dit est ce que tu parle anglais
j'ai dit oui est-ce que tu connais des
gens dans le showbiz je dis non je veux
lui dire non je connais personne ne veut
pas commencer et voilà c'est tout et le
lendemain ils m'appellent à l'époque et
pas de portable qu'il m'appelle chez moi
on dit prêt j'ai parlé à jacques igc
mois tout commence comme tu veux et
voilà si j'étais à la bonne époque très
bonne époque par là vous devenez attaché
de presse musique vous avez travaillé
pour roxy music genesis 4 stephen king
crimson bob marley jerry lee lewis
bashung bijoux et gainsbourg et quand
vous ferez de la télé philips va vous
mettre dehors en gros et vous deviendrez
la tâche et 13 mai c'est vrai vous
devenez intime avec le très intime oui
très intime mais bien peut-être parce
qu'on est à ascona sous les doux il y
avait une fidélité entre nous mais
sûrement mais moi j'étais déjà fan quand
on me l'a présenté à 25 ans et
finalement il m'a choisi quoi comme
attaché de presse j'étais content
j'étais heureux quoi tu m'appelles quand
je connaissais le vrai gainsbourg
touchant oui voix sensible et un spa oui
les albums dont je me suis occupé à
l'époque était bien l'homme à la tête de
chou vert mat et de soul rock and the
banker surtout un bon voilà et puis j'ai
arrêté de son premier album reggae
aux armes etc et là vous rencontrer
antoine de caunes qui produit et anime
chorus sur antenne 2 et vous dit jacky
vient faire le crétin sur le toit de
lempire ckac sports avenue de wagram
c'est vrai que se tourner chorus vient
faire le crétin sur le toit d'un empire
le samedi matin tu te mets à côté de moi
et tu dis rien oui c'est ça je servais à
rien en fait j'étais le premier
présentateur muet la télévision français
alors je m'étais les doigts l'anglais
l'oreille voilà je mettais un chapeau
sur la tête en fait ça me rassurait ses
balbutiements à la télé et ça leur
assurer que je fasse mes conneries à
peut-être il était face caméra il
parlait de bruce springsteen déjà voilà
et moi je suis de crétins vous dit que
j'avais voulu être animateur et lorsque
ça vous arrive vous avez trente ans mais
c'est pas vraiment votre ambition d'être
à n'ont jamais voulu faire un animateur
7le des rencontres et des gens quand
même permis ce soit ça vous vous seriez
resté attaché presse le directeur de
promotion tout le directeur artistique
ouais directeur de production chinoise
ont dit oui je voulais c'est là dedans
alors en 1981 chorus s'arrête et
jacqueline joubert la maman d'antoine de
caunes j'ai vraiment de la chance avec
cette famille qui est directrice de
l'unité jeunesse chante n 2 vous propose
de remplacer dorothée pour deux
émissions en fait au départ seulement
quand récré a2 et vous allez y rester
dix ans voilà c'est incroyable donc je
faisais récré a2 près à la même époque
avec les enfants du rock us voilà en
1982 pierre lescure directeur des
variétés d'antenne 2 créée les enfants
du rock avec antoine évidemment et là
vous participez à l'émission
houba houba
lescure crée aussi platine 45 la
première émission de clip que vous
animez absolument il m'a dit que
jacqueline j'ai pensé à toi j'ai dit ok
je le fais voilà où on tournait nos
clients c'était pas des types de maisons
de 10 ouais alors à l'époque les trois
émissions récré a2 pour les enfants
platine 45 pour les teenagers les
enfants du rock pour les branchés
faisaient le tour de la question
plus une émission quotidienne sur europe
1 plus les spectacles de dorothée vous
faites un peu le pitre sur scène fait
l'épouvantail oui l'épouvantail et puis
le directeur du génie je m'appelais seul
orange à quiche lorraine
elle va vous faites aussi un duo avec
lio tt ou c'est pas votre premier disque
un nom si on peut appeler ça un indice
non non c'était un clin d'oeil que non
c'est pas mon premier chef un single
pour jean luc azoulay tout augmente sauf
l'amour voilà ensuite att où ça marche
pas mal ça marche bien on était au top
50 mais voilà il y avait déjà canal + à
l'époque 84 alors écrit par chamfort qui
à l'époque était avec lio et puis par
bergman le parolier de bashung
pas mal pas mal j'étais bien entouré là
c'est sympa comme alors vous quittez
antenne 2 en 1986 pour tf1 ou frais
vitamines le club dorothée de jackie
chan face et la gloire quoi à bruce
était bien j'adorais cette période alors
quelles ont été les réactions de vos
parents à ce moment là bas au début une
part ans ça surtout mon père ma mère bon
elle était tout ce que je faisais
c'était bien quoi tu peux faire
n'importe quoi dans la caméra c'était
bien mais mon père était déjà plus jia
qui écoute là je fais attention à ce que
tu gagnes bien ta vie tu veux pas
prendre les boutiques ginon papa je
reste à la tête est finalement bon quand
tu me voyais tous les jours surtout à
l'époque du club dorothée ça les rassure
et huawei me dit voilà c'est bien le
métier ça s'est passé comment quelles
ont été les réactions des gens dans le
métier même si j'ai été un peu surpris
parce que c'était la fin j'étais une
carrière un peu atypique quoi parce que
je fais un des rares à avoir fait ces
trois émissions vous avez cité quoi
c'était vrai que c'était entre récré a2
platine 45 des enfants du rock c'était
totalement différent je vois c'est le
personnage de jackie qui devait plaire
fodé sylla s'échappe bien sûr vous avez
créé un personnage voilà ça fait dans le
type d'émission voilà c'est ça laisse
avec ces rares personnes a eu des
émissions aussi différentes et heureux
qu'une seule fois c'est pas par
prétention a senti une seule des
relations avec les médias ça s'est passé
comment très bien tout de suite en plus
je connaissais pas ce que j'ai déjà été
attaché 3 0 donc vous reconnaissez oui
j'ai appelé tous les journalistes à
l'époque pourquoi c'est mes artistes
quoi
l'argent allait gagner du blé ouais
j'avais dû doubler ouais bah oui quand
on fait trois émissions même sur antenne
2 dans un doublé sur tf1 c'était sympa
oui vous avez mis un peu de côté oui
heureusement acheter un appartement
chercher une maison c'est encore mieux
c'est encore mieux et l'amour alors
toutes les filles devez vous tomber dans
les bras oui oui oui tout est pas tout
mais pas mal dès qu'on fait de la télé
couvert les meilleurs moments de cette
époque c'est quoi ce qui c'était quand
j'ai fait pas tenu 45 c'était vraiment
une émission que j'ai adoré où j'ai reçu
tout le monde quoi c'était une chance
contournable aussi bien les chanteurs
les acteurs que les humoristes j'adore
le pire moment ça a été aussi platine 45
c'est la seule fois où j'ai eu un vrai
tracas l'atc quand j'ai reçu catherine
deneuve ah oui oui j'étais tétanisée
déjà à l'idée qu'elle fasse pas de 45
pourtant j'ai reçus tout le monde
acquiesce et rajoelina
j'étais tétanisée incapable de sortir
j'étais très mauvais j'avais été mauvais
mais là j'étais je peux pas sortir un
mot quoi c'était terrible alors après
l'arrêt du club dorothée en 1997 vous
retrouvez un petit peu tricard de la
télévision hertzienne vous rejoignez tfj
la télévision juive vous animerez leurs
habits jackie chan de 1998 à 2005 ça
c'est marrant on n'y avait pas de moyens
j'avais acheté des sièges de synagogues
rouge
avec une incruste merdeuse m'enfin les
gens venaient quoi on parle et pendant
50 minutes c'est plus une conversation
que j'ai des problèmes avec les tradi
quand vous appelez ça un méchoui jeu se
fait insulter
nous depuis même je me souviens quand
j'avais invité stéphane bern qui donc
est comme moi juif ashkénaze et je lui
dis alors est-ce que tu as mizrahim du
web j'aime bien j'aime bien je rêve vu
la jordanie la le standard a sauté
on a laissé
ensuite sur ab1 et idf1 où vous êtes
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
nostalgique aujourd'hui de l'époque de
platine 45 j'ai bien aimé cette période
c'est pas un stade j j'aime pas trop
revenir en arrière non mais je suis
content de l'avoir fait quoi voilà et
vous avez de la rancune contre des gens
de l'époque qui sont mal comportés avec
vous
il y en a qui sont mal comportés oui oui
patrice blanc francard pour une telle
cité car voici pierre lescure à aux
enfants du rap du rock il a voulu me
direz de platine 45 menée par yves et de
bron lyon voulait un peu moins un peu
quand même mais si c'était à refaire
votre carrière qu'est ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil jacky ce que j'en
ferais pas pareil parce que je les ratés
et je m'en veux beaucoup c'est mon année
sur europe 1
j'ai merdé j'avais trop de choses
j'avais trop de choses j'ai pas réussi
ça j'adore la radio ouais je referai
europe 1 d'une autre manière j'ai
négligé ça c'est le jour vous allez
mourir oui ça va arriver non qu'est-ce
que les cons marque sur votre tombe ici
jacubowicz
voilà merci jacques liste est très
heureux de rallumer le numéro merci les
corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu